Alex OK Conor welcome to the show how
splendidly we progress uh the first time
on a Skype call second time was in
person in Austin and
now something of a sort of cinematic
production I fear that next time we'll
be in 3D or something it's good to see
you again good to see you as well mate
uh how are you feeling in the aftermath
of Peter
Hitchens validated
Vindicated uh I must say that I was a
little
bit I was in two minds about uploading
that that interview he does there was a
bit of a a mixture of opinion coming
from him he wasn't speaking entirely
clearly must have been something on his
mind he said as he's getting up to walk
out I don't think you should run this
and I'm thinking look if if if my guest
tells me that they don't want me to run
an interview for any reason it could be
because they've had a bad hair day then
I'll respect that and so I thought damn
am I really going to have to you know be
the bigger man here and just not post
this at all but then he kept saying oh
run it if you like I can't stop you from
running it I just don't think you have
any moral right to run it and I asked
him why and he said it was because I a
propagandist for drug decriminalization
a subject which prior to that by the way
I'd spoken about once
ever and that I'd intentionally tricked
him to appear on my podcast in order
that I might fool him into a
conversation about drugs now before the
podcast started I said Mr Hitchens you
have uh about three subject areas that
we both talk about where I think there's
a bit of crossover that you've either
spoken about or indeed written books
about and those are the
decriminalization of drugs I also
mentioned this in my email the existence
of God or religion I should say God and
religion is the topic and uh the third
was monarchy at this point he says well
you know monarchy is a bit
boring okay notice listener that he did
not take this opportunity to tell me
that he thought that drugs were a bit
boring and would rather not really talk
about drugs at all or for too long okay
fine so I'm thinking I agree with you
the monarchy is incredibly boring in
fact that's the entirety of my point
about the monarchy is that it's
essentially just boring more than
anything else so let's just do the other
two so I say we'll run for about an hour
ideally he says that's good you know and
I say but you know if the conversation
flows it can be an hour and a half it
could be two hours
and okay he says well look you know I
say sometimes they can be 3 hours long
he says well 3 hours might be a bit long
but we'll see how we do so I'm thinking
about an hour and a half an hour and a
half on what was now in my view two
subjects so at about 40 minutes into
this potentially 90-minute podcast on
the same topic when he told me that
we've been going around for too long on
said topic I was a little bit bemused
but I did think to myself maybe I've
done something wrong here maybe I have
upset him in a way that obviously was
not intentional you know I wasn't trying
to bring this out of him although you
know it does do quite well for the
channel it's not like it's something I
would do intentionally so I did think to
myself well maybe I've done something so
I listened back back and I send it to
some friends including you and thank you
for listening to it and and saying that
like most people just said you have to
run this he's he's been completely
unreasonable and so there have been
criticisms people have said well you
know what it was a bit boring or yeah it
was going around in circles I submit
that that was his fault by the way uh
because he does this thing which I've
noticed in a lot of philosophical and
political discussion uh which is the
sort of I know this one attitude when
you do a lot of interviews I find that
you have a sort of I know this one and
so they answer the question that they
heard not the answer that was asked
exactly and and it and it
happens especially when it's it's easy
enough to make that mistake if you're
not listening carefully so he was
talking about uh the well I I asked him
about the decriminalization of of of
cannabis and he says that well this will
essentially mean that a lot of more
children will be smoking it he he had
this contention that children would end
up smoking cannabis and I thought to
myself well okay I can understand that
concern of course but I think the
tobacco industry has suffered quite a
blow in still being perfectly legal to
buy as an adult but but kids just aren't
smoking cigarettes anymore it's just not
a thing that's really done why is that
in other words we've had quite a
successful education campaign whereby
it's not popular for kids to smoke
anymore and yet it's still perfectly
legal can't we have a similar approach
to cannabis potentially by the way not a
good view potentially a perfectly
rebuttable view I'm not sure but I
wouldn't know because I didn't get a
rebuttal to that view instead I just
heard you know all you can do is is do
the whole which by the way is a
genuinely quite tired line in this
debate the whole oh what about smoking
or indeed another point where I brought
up alcohol well all you can say is what
about alcohol what about
smoking and that's not what I was doing
at least I contend that's not what I was
doing because that's what he heard he
goes oh I know this one I've heard this
before yeah and and you haven't read my
book it didn't seem to occur to him that
it is possible Mr Hitchens to read your
book and yet still after having done so
disagree with you
yeah it's sometimes when you hear people
speak especially guys that are a little
bit older I think there is a there is
kind of like reverse agism that goes on
which is who is this sort of young
whipper snapper person who I maybe have
heard of or haven't heard of much and um
almost like a Blas kind of discrediting
of the thing it's like this is and this
is your show but it's my show so to
speak and um yeah it was like I thought
his attitude was p
and unlikable and uh my favorite part
was when he threw the pillow at the
microphone throwing the pillow down with
and and he kept sort of walking back
over he says he says you know I I don't
want you to post this and obsessed with
no opinion about you before I decided
that I absolutely do not like you it was
it was uh it was quite something and a
lot of people messaged me saying hey
like uh I'm so sorry that happened like
you know you're doing all right and I'm
thinking
sorry sorry I thought there's no way
that this is happening I mean
when it looked like he was about to get
up I thought surely not but then
internally I'm thinking like go on then
do it do it because I don't think I've
done anything wrong here it was the
podcasting equivalent of come on mate
have a go yeah but you know you know the
weirdest thing was because he he sort of
gets up to go and he walks out and he
stands at the door and he's and it's I
wish you kind of could have seen his
body language it was it was very there's
one point where you can see it when he
walks back into shot and he says
something and then after he said it he
just sort of stands there looking at me
as if to say like what have you got a go
and so he keep going like I'm going to
go
now I'm
going I'm going to I'm going and waiting
the podcast playing hard to get
equivalent it must have been something
like that yeah it was like it was like
the person who wants the fight but wants
to look like they didn't initiate the
fight and and I don't think it's my
fault I'll leave it up to the to the
Judgment of The Listener or the viewer I
don't think it's my fault that he spent
17 minutes 17 count them 17 entire
minutes stood at the door telling me how
much he personally dislikes me telling
me how much he doesn't want to see me
again I've I've wanted to do that for as
long as I've known you so well we'll see
how we do yeah today uh you're going to
try and convince me of the existence of
God today you managed to convince chat
GPT that's right which means does it
mean that I'm smarter than chat GPT if
you convince me more quickly or more
slowly or not at all I don't know um I I
I do know that it it means that well
well chat gbt if it's going to inherit
eternal life I I sort of wonder how
that's going to work in heaven I I don't
know I mean I I don't know if recursive
nightmare for everyone as they walk
around and they've got the chat GPT logo
floating about yeah the interesting
thing about chat GPT is that you you
sort of you can you can essentially
convince it of anything and so I wasn't
quite sure if it was even a very good
video idea because I'm sure I could just
as easily convince it that God doesn't
exist well at least you can be thankful
that it wasn't able to say it had no
opinion of you before but it absolutely
does not like you and then get up and
walk out quite right some people in the
comments did say that at least you know
chat GPT stuck around until the end that
would be a task in fact that's another
video idea I got chat GPT to storm out
of an
interview even I probably couldn't do
that uh didn't this get brought up you
debated Ben Shapiro yesterday how did
that go I haven't even seen you it went
well I think uh it will probably be out
around the time of this this interview
maybe slightly before slightly
afterwards uh it was it was a good
conversation we were discussing whether
or not religion is good for
society and stand for young Benjamin to
take at the moment I suppose so I mean
it was a very much sort of don't mention
the war type type scenario um I mean the
the producers had said look we want this
to be an evergreen conversation we want
this to be something that people can
listen to at any point and also Ben had
just the night before been to the Oxford
Union and I haven't seen that yet either
but saw that he went had at it with a
bunch of uh people on the other side of
the fence so to speak he didn't have a
very good time he said to me that it was
the most tense thing that he's ever done
wow the most tense thing he's ever ever
been a part of well I saw something that
was kind of interesting was the video
was only shot on what appeared to be
iPhone yes uh so there was no maybe they
just wanted to get it up early as
opposed to waiting for the Oxford unions
official video to come through seems to
be the case they they do seem to be
planning to upload it in fact when I was
recording with Ben I think his team were
in The Green Room sort of furiously
subtitling to try and get it out
potentially before the Oxford Union I'm
not entirely sure but I mean it sounded
like
a a hell of an evening and so the next
day he was saying that it sort of felt
like a nice break from that what to sit
opposite you you are the comfortable
leather pair of shoes that he can put on
I think Ben
relaxes in argumentation I think he
genuinely enjoys it I I think there's no
contradiction to say that he was having
some time off by sitting there and and
and having a having a SP but he was
having a break from the politics in
other words he was able to just argue
about something a bit more perennial and
a little less uh a little less fiery I
suppose what have you learned so you
are I've been a massive fan of you since
before you came on the podcast and since
then we've become friends and you've
come out to see me in Austin we spent a
ton of time together you're probably my
favorite person to watch debate people
because it's kind of a little bit like
watching uh Batman versus Spider-Man or
something because I know you well and
we've argued a lot but I and I know
maybe Ben Shapiro but I don't know what
will happen when these two people come
together
you were president of sock sock detic
Society yes yeah you part of debate sock
and all of this other stuff at Oxford
given that you've got a relatively
illustrious Heritage of both formal and
informal debates what is your assessment
of Ben
Shapiro's debating style his ethical
consistency his ability to deploy logic
etc etc now that you've gone mano a mano
in the ring well he has obviously a an
incredibly High verbal IQ he can
construct a sentence out of nowhere and
do it very quickly and he's also very
difficult to interrupt not that I
particularly wanted to I mean he'll he
he would throw sort of maybe two or
three points out at once and and you
want to Bud in and do them one by one
you don't want to be rude of course so
so I let him finish but it was amazing
how they just glued together into one
wall of text you know I I I've seen
comments on some of the videos that I
was watching of him in preparation to
talk to him where people would would
were not being funny in saying that they
play the video on 0.75 speed because it
makes him sound normal there was there
sort of an episode with uh with
Constantin and Francis trigonometry and
he's talking about religion and its
relation to the fenyl crisis and people
were saying that if you and it was very
fast and if you play it on
0.75 you forget that you've done that
and you're just hearing somebody talk at
a normal volume at a normal speed and
then Constantin comes in sounding like a
blue whale or something out of nowhere
so he's he's he's very quick yeah um but
also I thought very charitable this is
the thing I think people get bench airo
wrong I went to his Cambridge Union
event uh
after this this discussion SL debate in
because it was in Cambridge that's
that's why we were why we were out there
and and so I went to this event and I
was talking to a lot of the students
afterwards and you hear a lot of people
saying about bench per that he's a bit
of a bit of a grifter or well I'm not
really a fan or you have the sort of
secret fans who are sat in the chamber
going like well you you know it's it's I
think it's just it's important you know
if you're going to disagree with someone
you sort of have to hear the thing that
you're going to disagree with In the
Flesh you can say that you like bapiro
it's okay you know um but people see
this this side of him of the sort of
slightly sneering SMY owning the college
student kind of thing but I think in
many ways he matches the energy that
he's
given and so taking him seriously and
listening to what he's saying and being
willing to to concede a point to him he
will do the same thing and I think that
happened in this conversation you know
it's it's
steadfast we're saying what we think to
each other at one point we both accuse
each other simultaneously of being
delusional but in such a manner that if
you say something you get a sort of like
yeah yeah no that's a fair point
actually maybe we should put it this way
instead or or yeah you know actually I
see what you're saying no you're right I
should have said this instead that kind
of attitude which is the kind of thing
that people think bencho is incapable of
for some reason humility you know what I
mean yeah and it's a kind of it's a it's
a hidden humility because it comes out
not in the attitude not in the not in a
sort of he not going to like give way to
you emotionally he's not going to be
like oh you're right it would just be if
you if you pay attention to the way he's
constructing an argument and changing it
subtly based on your responses you know
that he really is listening and really
is trying to engage with what you're
actually saying and that's a kind of
humility that I don't think can really
be
faked yeah I am friends with a bunch of
guys that have worked with him over the
years and uh I know for a fine fact that
part of his debate prep involves a
number of break glass in case of mass
offense uh sort of Escape hatches and
that there's layers of how uh deep and
how aggressive he can go so I would love
to know actually I might email him and
find out what he's got on you just in
case I ever needs to actually pull that
pin um but well he said to me when he
walked in uh I saw the Peter Hitchens
thing as everybody's been saying to me
recently so he'd at least seen that so
he knows how I behave and he he he knows
in other words that if he did start sort
of screaming at me that I would probably
just sit there and take it right okay a
like the philosophical cck that you are
right yeah yeah you're kind of a little
another quote for the for the Twitter
bio I
think yeah have you have you updated it
to I absolutely do not I've decided I do
not like you Peter Hitchens it's it's in
there somewhere I think it's I actively
dislike you is the quote that's now in
my bio I'm constantly shifting it around
I don't think I'll ever get rid of
unusually it you were doing what was it
that you did for a while making theists
question their beliefs and lesbians
question their sexuality since I don't
know what you're talking about I
remember that in your I have no idea
what you're talking about we really
have't known each other a long time you
know what I found yesterday I was uh I
sort of stumbled across it while looking
for an email trying to find out where we
were filming today h and I found the
original email that you sent me in must
have been 2019 when we first met and it
was amazing it was this sort of hi Alex
uh been watching your stuff for a while
like it was sort of three four
paragraphs of texts I'd love to sit down
and have a conversation with you I think
that your views will be of big interest
to my viewers and then I I've already
spoken to these people and it was a
bunch of people that I I hadn't heard of
wasn't really in my sphere um and it
signed off Chris Williamson voodo events
fantastic yeah wow my previous life yeah
I had uh filling nightclubs in my
signature until only six months ago and
I realized I needed to get rid of it but
no it's um it's cool man I think you
know if I could invest money in people
uh you George Mack Zach my housemate
Ginder Bogle Rob Henderson you know even
Southerland I don't think that the the
market has priced in his talent and um
it's so funny cuz like what I did for
almost all of my career in NTI was find
different kind of talent right it was
like degenerate party talent but find
kids that had good work ethic and and
and some skill and then bring them in
and sort of train them up uh so keeping
a finger on the pulse of what's
happening with regards to Trends if who
is appropriate and blah blah blah but
yeah man I'm you know there is a point I
I will happily say it now there is a
point that's going to occur within the
next few years where something happens
with you being involved that just
catapults you into like super stardom
like I would absolutely bet a [__] ton
of money that this is going to happen
you've got some what's that big thing
you're doing soon can we announce the
big thing that you're doing soon that
even bigger debate I think not only
because it's still very much up in the
air okay however if and when that
happens if and when that happens going
to break the internet that could be
unless this does it for me well very
well might do this is the biggest
platform you've been on so when was the
last time that you're aware of in your
world of philosophy that something like
a a step change like the equivalent of
the discovery of the higs boson happened
in philosophy yeah just every now and
again something does come along that's a
bit revolutionary and a recent example
and by recent consider we're talking
about the history of philosophy here
20th century uh the theory of knowledge
is completely exploded by a man called
Edmund Geier uh and this is
this is actually I I think quite
fascinating I'll be interested to hear
what you think about this so knowledge
is really difficult to Define people
didn't used to have as much of a problem
with it like if you had to give a
definition of knowledge what does it
mean to know something this isn't like a
trick question I'm just I'm just
interested what do you think to know
something uh to be able to accurately
predict what happens in the world okay
so it's got something to do with it
being true in the world and your ability
to predict but you can also think about
things in the past right like you can
know that Napoleon existed or something
so so prediction ability to infer yeah
to infer to to sort of to have some kind
of belief about the world which is
accurate which is accurate which is
which is true
um sure but then imagine for example
you're in a you're in like a locked
concrete box with no windows MH and I
don't know like a like some Voodoo
Mystic tells you that it's raining
outside and they they're just like
insane they're on drugs or something and
and and they just tell you that it's
raining they're convinced of it and and
for some reason you believe them totally
irrationally and it just so happens that
it is by coincidence raining outside did
you know right so you have a belief
about the world which is true but it
would seem very strange to say that you
know that it's raining outside right and
so since Plato and the Ancients we've
sort of had a consensus on the idea that
knowledge is Justified true belief JTB
so you need to have a belief that's
true you need to of course believe it to
be true but you have to also be
justified in that belief and that's what
makes it knowledge so if you if you see
that it's raining outside through the
window and you believe that it's raining
outside and then it's true that it's
raining outside now you can say you know
that it's raining as right okay and this
is just essentially consensus for for
potentially thousands of years we're
talking about here and then Edmund G in
at least one account this may be
apocryphal but it said that he sort of
hadn't really published anything
and was being compelled to to get
something in a journal and he just sort
of reaches into his papers of random
things he's been writing pulls up the
one on the top and and hands it off for
for submission this is about two or
three pages long and it just upends the
whole thing with with essentially
counter example which are now known as
gatier cases so his example was to say
okay imagine that you're in a job
interview and uh the your your interview
goes really quite well and the person
person says to you you know I I I
shouldn't really be saying this but I I
I think you've got it and so you go back
outside and you're feeling pretty good
there are other candidates but you
you've got a a pretty Justified reason
to think that you're going to get the
job then the other guy goes in and while
you're waiting for him you know you're
just fiddling around in your pocket and
and you take out whatever you got in
your pocket and you've got 10 coins and
you're just fiddling with your 10 coins
so you develop a Justified belief that
the person who's going to get the job
has 10 coins in his
pocket cuz you you're pretty sure you're
going to get the job and you just by
chance you just had a look and you've
got 10 coins so you got a Justified
belief that the person who's going to
get the job has 10 coins in their pocket
there's been some kind of like freak
mistake or something maybe they've read
your name wrong on the form or they the
person who told you they thought you got
it meant to speak to the other person
but it turns out the other guy actually
gets the job but just by sheer
coincidence he also has 10 coins in his
pocket the question is did you know that
the person who would get the job would
have 10 coins in his pocket
you have a Justified true belief that
the person who gets the job would have
10 coins in his pocket but it seems in
this circumstance you didn't know that
that just seems wrong seems like a wrong
account it's a bit of a sort of clunky
example and he gives another one which
is also maybe a little bit clunky but
this sort of Sparks this type of Affair
called a getia case well you told me I
think over dinner the best Getti a case
which was the person behind the Hedge
yes so this is better I think so so I I
think it's actually better firstly it's
better to experience them for yourself
and there are simpler explanations as
well so I was dy I was in a car driving
around a bend and Over the Hedge I see
this this small child sort of bouncing
up and down behind the Hedge and I
thought to myself oh cool I'm about to
see a horse I mean it looked like the
kid was riding a horse and I I was like
yeah cool we're going to see a horse and
we ride around this Bend and the kid was
actually on uh his or her like dad's
back and that's why she was high up and
and bouncing up and down but just by
sheer coincidence in the field behind
them was a horse and I couldn't believe
it I thought I've just experienced a
gtia case I had a Justified true belief
that I was about to see a horse the
difficulty with that one is that it's
probably not justified to believe that I
was about to see a horse because I
probably should have thought that it
could have been a father but a much more
simple example and this actually
happened to me once I was in the the US
capital building in the in the Crypt and
they have the clock that used to be in
the House of
Representatives and
they said that the reason they replaced
it and brought it down here was because
they were fed up of winding it up they
didn't want to wind it anymore and I
looked at it and I and I asked the the
tour guide lady I said oh well do they
still wind it while it's down here and
she said no and I
thought but it's the real it's the time
it says the time right now and she was
like oh right yeah it must be a
coincidence and I was like the only one
looking around like hey that's that's
pretty that's pretty extraordinary I
mean I guess it happens twice a day
right but this is a geet case if you if
your watch break but you don't know that
it's broken you got a reliable watch but
today it's broken and you look at the
time and it's stopped on halfast
3 and so you look at it and you think oh
it must be halfast three and it does
actually just so happen to be half past
three did you know it was half past
three that's a Geier case Justified true
belief and yet seems weird to say that
you that you know it so geier's
Revelation here was something like what
you're talking about a sort of genuine
novelty in history of philosophy and
they come about quite rarely but they
they do occur this episode is brought to
you by element element is a tasty
electrolyte drink mix with everything
that you need and nothing that you don't
it's a healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks it's got a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium you might
ask what do I want with an electrolyte
drink well it'll regulate your appetite
it'll curb Cravings it'll help improve
your brain function best of all it
tastes phenomenal first thing in the
morning this orange element salt in
water is outstanding your adenosine
system that caffeine acts on isn't even
active for the first 90 minutes of the
day so it's pointless having a morning
coffee your adrenal system which is what
salt Aon is active so this will make you
feel more alert more awake and improve
your hydration best of all they've got a
nobs no questions asked refund policy so
you can buy it and if you do not like it
for any reason they will give you your
money back that's how confident they are
that you love it head to drink LM nt.com
slod wisdom to get a free sample pack of
all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink LM nt.com
slod wisdom what happens Downstream from
that in the world of
philosophy just a massive migraine
basically people start coming up with
arguments responses you know so people
start say oh maybe it's not justified
true belief maybe it's like causally
related justification to the cause of
the but presumably kind of in the same
way that I guess a new um scientific
discovery is made about the way that we
metabolize glucose or about what happens
if you take this amount of nicotine or
the role of Metformin in PR preventing
high blood pressure or something there
are stacked on top of that one
assumption a number of other assumptions
but with philosophy especially something
I imagine like the philosophy of
knowledge it's so
foundational that having this entire
universe built on this particular
Foundation then means that the entire
house of cards collapses down and people
then need to rebuild all of this
nightmare on on top of it yeah well most
the philosophy is just a consistency
test as it is in something like
mathematics it's just that we accept
that there are certain axioms that even
even mathematical axioms you know you
can you can you can question them um I
mean veritasium just made a quite good
video about ukian geometry and how it
sort of just accepted for a very long
time that for example you know if if you
have a right
angle then it if you sort of join up the
two lines coming off that right angle
you'll create a triangle whose interior
angles add up to 180 degrees and
then people start thinking about what
about like curved geometric spaces what
if you do this on a globe if you put a
triangle on a globe the angles aren't
going to wet up in that way and these
These are sort of like uh axioms of
mathematics that essentially they don't
necessarily get proved wrong or thrown
out but people realize that you can
think about things differently and so
most of what we're doing is actually
just testing for consistency and so
there it's actually quite difficult to
prove an axiom wrong because you kind of
need an axiom just to get off the ground
and the rest of everything you're doing
is just consistency tests with that
Axiom this is one of the most
interesting things I learned from you
maybe in the first ever episode that we
did as you were teaching me about the
difference between ethics and matter
ethics as someone that isn't formally
trained in either um and you I use this
all the time it's such an interesting uh
mental model to think that in order for
me and you to have a discussion about
ethics our meta ethical Foundation we
need to agree on that because out of
that if we don't the entire ethical
discussion on top will just continue to
fall back to uh definitional problems
and well you're presuming that so you
can't discuss the stuff that happens on
top of you unless you discuss the stuff
that's underneath and this is It's the
entirety of the trans debate right it's
the entirety of lexical uh overwhelm
that if you can't
agree on the definition of
words the argument about the words and
what they then refer to just collapses
in on itself and continuously just falls
back to an argument about the definition
of words yes this happens with for
example
Freedom there are lots of different ways
of conceiving a freedom famously freedom
from and freedom to right uh is is
freedom just being left alone or is
freedom being empowered to do things
that you should be able to do and then
when you have people arguing about
nationalized healthcare for example one
person says to be free you need to be
healthy and one person says to be free
you need to spend your own money as you
please and not be forced to fund other
people's Healthcare now both of these
people can be right they're just
defining Freedom differently of course
so you're quite right and um that's why
met ethics is quite important I mean AJ
a pointed out in language truth and
logic that the vast majority of ethical
debate is not ethical debate it's
descriptive debate it's factual debate
if you look at the so-called ethical
debate gun laws in America for example
people are talking about statistics
they're saying X many people die per
year oh well don't you know that more
children are killed by swimming pools uh
don't you know that like if we in if we
introduce you know if we ban certain
types of weapons or blah blah blah that
this many less people will die all these
kind of things are just descriptive
factual statements that people like to
dispute with each other and that's why
they like say we have the facts on our
side but the actual ethical question
that that undergoes it all is is is
hardly ever even reached you know and so
most of the time people are actually
arguing about that I mean the same thing
with an abortion debate for example you
know questions about biology when does
Consciousness emerge can it survive on
its own with outside of the womb this
week or this week you know this kind of
stuff will it increase the number of
women who die or decrease the number of
women who die but none of these are
ethical questions and people think
they're having an ethical debate when
they're actually just having a debate
about facts that can be resolved in
principle by scientific empirical
inquiry the ethical question
is the more interesting one that's often
assumed and if people think that they
agree with each other or understand each
other in the same way on that ethical
first point then you're in for a
disaster what do you wish if they don't
I mean yeah what do you wish that uh
more people could realize when it comes
to understanding ethics and consistency
in their own lives is there something
that a little red pill or a particular
Insight that you wish you could deposit
into the mind of the populace that you
think would make their lives a little
bit more easy or their sense making a
bit more simple I don't know about
making lives easier but I I I do think
that people should recognize the extent
to which emotions dominate our ethical
thinking I mean I I'm I take a I think
it's seen as a relatively Ecentric view
that ethics just is the expression of
emotion this was something popularized
by that same AJ AER in a book that was
so troubling to the philosophical
consensus at the time that there's a
story of a I think it was like a maybe a
dean of baile colge or something who
when a student came in everybody wanted
to talk about this book and they were so
scared of the implications of it that he
literally throws it out of the window
because he he just doesn't want to talk
about it because a is talking about how
the only things that can be meaningful
are those which are analytically true or
empirically verifiable if you're if the
statement you're making
isn't isn't something you can at least
in principle test empirically or
something that's just a torty two and
two is four then what you're saying is
literally meaningless and people came to
him and said well what about ethical
statements you can't prove these in
principle and they're not torical and he
said well the way that they're
meaningful is that they are expressions
of emotion and it gives birth to this
view called emotivism which is really a
philosophy of language more than a
philosophy of Ethics it it tries to
describe what people mean when they say
good or bad and famously he comes up
with this analogy that saying murder is
wrong is like saying boo murder and
saying murder is or you saying given to
charity is good as like saying yay
charity it's just an expression emotion
it's not even the same thing as saying I
like charity or I don't like murder
because those things can be true or
false they have truth value it could be
true that I it is just a psychological
fact that I don't like murder he means
murder is wrong that statement is just
the expression of the emotion y boo
murder and I think even if you don't
agree with him to that extent as I more
or less do if you begin to recognize the
extent to which emotions are dominating
your ethical conduct pay attention to
what it feels like when you analyze
something as wrong
I think it belongs in the same category
as because you've got this sort of
emotion site of uh soup of sort of
stimulus going on inside of you what is
it like to feel like something is wrong
and and we know that
people people seem to change what they
rationally do based on how they're
feeling I mean I don't know if you've
come across Terror management Theory
before it would surprise me if you
hadn't the the idea that all human
beings are doing is trying to manage
their fear of death and that that's what
motivates all all human activity and
there have been some interesting studies
in this some of them are harder to
replicate than others but I mean the the
first one the most famous was uh some I
think Arizona state judges and they were
being asked to recommend a bond for the
solicitation of
prostitution and what the researchers
did was they asked them to fill out a
just a form first and on half of the
forms they just mentioned death they
just put in a few questions about death
and what do think happens after death
you know who would you put in your will
that kind of stuff nothing nothing too
extreme and they found that the bond
that was set by the judges Inc I mean I
think the I think the average bond for
the control group was was less than $100
and for the ones who are reminded their
of their death was more like2 or $300 on
average what does that imply so the the
interpretation of teror magment theory
was that when we're reminded of our
deaths we need to tempor arily more
heavily reaffirm the sort of death
denying aspects of our culture the
reason that we do things the reason we
create art the reason that we get out of
bed the reason that we have
conversations like this is because in in
some way it's traceable back to trying
to essentially deny our own death Ernest
Becker wrote a book called The denal of
death right and this is this is
essentially the idea and so for judges
it might be something like by
participating in the legal system
they're participating in something
that's a bit beyond them and therefore
it exists outside of their own mortality
and so the thesis this mortality
salience hypothesis as it's known is
that for a judge if they're reminded of
Their Own Death what they will
temporarily be compelled to do is more
harshly reaffirm that thing that is you
know the the death denying aspect of of
their daily life which is participation
in the legal system so more harsh
penalties right okay that to me seem the
explanation seems a little bit tenuous
I'm not sure about that but it does seem
strange that when you remind people of
Their Own
Death they will
you know Christians and like Muslims
will become more derogatory towards Jews
people of different nationalities will
sit further away from each other people
will when asked to draw pictures of
currency will draw physically larger
pictures of
currency people's opinion on whether
they prefer a picture of a forest or a
picture of you know Suburban
neighborhood will change on
average like these these things are
extraordinary just from being reminded
of your own death of course the biggest
manifestation of the denial of death
would be religion and that that would
also explain why you know religion deals
a lot with death and why why sort of if
you remind people of Their Own Death
they also become religious which by the
way is true of atheists as well people
who don't believe in God will still
become more religious even if they don't
ultimately believe in God when reminded
of Their Own
Death yeah I
um I've been thinking a good bit
recently about how
people do an awful lot especially in the
modern world that is death denialism
masquerading as something else I think
the productivity movement very much is
that you know trying to fit more into
less time if only I could get more life
more work more output out of my one unit
of days or whatever um I think that a
good chunk of the health and fitness
world uh the longevity movement the
biohacking movement all of that is
absolutely death denialism and you can
see as well nutrition all of the the
arguments about is it better for me to
be carnivore or vegan should I go high
carb or low carb can I do intermittent
fasting should I be using ketones
exogeneously ultimately the reason that
I think these arguments are
so vehement and
passionate especially when you think
it's diet guys right it's diet it's like
I want to
have aspartame you want to have sugar
like how does my asame consumption or
you impact your sugar consumption but
what it hits at for a lot of people is a
certainty about I can predict and
project out into the future how long I'm
going to be able to live or die and I'm
going to be able to compare myself to
this other person and
their
conviction in their particular approach
which derates my Approach
implicitly suggests to me you're going
to die sooner
and that causes me to be [__]
terrified it's the same reason why
people are
so how long do you need to do it's not
VO2 max that's most important it's HRV
it's not its resting heart rate it's not
its galvanic skin temperature we're not
looking at that we're looking at tmia
length we're not looking at that it's
whatever all of the things you know the
entire field of health and fitness which
I'm a big part of uh I I think is a good
chunk of it is death denialism just
masquerading as getting big
biceps yes uh so sometimes it is more
obvious I think we need more nihilists
uh Health influencers who will sort of
say you know I need to I need to when
the question is asked you know should
you eat white bread or brown bread or
whatever it is you know they'll sort of
begin with the question it sort of
depends on your your your views on the
intrinsic value of life um also if
you're a bit of a utilitarian I
mean people often say that being
unhealthy might be unethical because in
a country with nationalized Healthcare
you're a burden you're you're you're a
burden but but are you I mean who costs
the taxpayer more the person who eats a
bunch of burgers and has a heart attack
and dies instantly or the person who
lives into old age and therefore has
some kind of long-term health problem
like Alzheimer's I need to I need to
interject here so you ring me probably
three years ago four years ago you ring
me and I'm in the
gym and you say something like what are
you doing it's like I'm in the gym what
are you doing uh just whatever whatever
catch up a little bit I was like what's
going on what's what's happening and you
said I'm trying nihilism
and I said what do you mean and he went
as a life philosophy I'm trying
nihilism and I still don't know what you
mean so how is
your experiment to make nihilism great
again going well I was getting a bit Fed
Up of people
saying oh you're an nihilist oh you're
an a well they wouldn't say it in the
terms of nihilism theyd say are you're
an atheist yeah right yeah I mean I
there was a there was a cliff of Jord
Peterson on the Lex Freedman podcast
um and he says oh you're secular and you
and you go to art galleries yeah well
what makes you think you're secular and
the head turn is real he he he does that
you know yeah and I thought to myself
what on Earth are you talking about man
you think you can't be an atheist and
enjoy art now I tried my best to
understand what he was getting at and I
think he was trying to basically say
that in order to enjoy art you need to
have some kind of value and in order to
have any kind of surface level value you
can always ask the why that why that
question why do you value this why you
know the the classic sort of why do you
why do you go to school to get a good
grade well you don't just want the grade
why do you get the grade you do it to
get a good job and so on and so forth
happens with value and so why do you go
why do you value art because you maybe
Value beauty or something and Peterson's
whole thing is that whatever's at the
top of this value hierarchy is in his
definition Divine he he just defines it
as such and so he essentially said that
like you know people claim that they
that they are nihilists but they don't
live like that I thought well what would
it mean to really live like a nihilist
and you know I I guess I tried to nasiz
but he's right in to the extent that I
think most people don't live like their
nihilists what would the definition of
living like anilist be I think it would
just mean the rejection
of of of any such thing as a
non-contingent reason for acting be more
accessible you you would need
to to to really think that there's no
reason to do anything outside of
essentially your crude preferences and
biological drives right
and I think the reason why people think
that nihilism is unlivable is because
they have this image of somebody just
immediately becoming a raskolnikov type
figure and just committing a murder or
something but they forget that these
people still have their memory and
they're going to be embedded in in a in
a culture and an upbringing that's their
preferences are essentially still going
to be aligned I mean pendulette was once
asked if you're an atheist why don't you
kill and
assault you every person you want to and
and he says I do I do kill and assault
everybody I want to which is precisely
nobody you know and very clever gets a
bit of an Applause but I mean the the
difficult question ethically is what
happens when somebody doesn't have that
view what happens when somebody does
just disagree with you but I don't know
it it was It was kind of boring just to
interject out to so you could see um um
the meaning making machine of society
and cultural norms as being useful to
constrain the behavior of those outlier
people the ones who would go out and and
commit the Litany of mass murders but
you know Mom told me that I'm not
supposed to squash bugs when I was 5
years old and this is now carried on
through but yeah I think you know for
most people we are the descendants of
the people who avoided at least for the
most part killing people that were close
to us and we feel a lot of the time like
we're now close to each other yes yes um
I think that's probably true the issue
is that the more that we try to explain
away
these these mechanisms uh we try to
understand why in our evolutionary
history we might have
evolved certain moral tabos this kind of
stuff it begins to essentially take the
complete ethical Force out of it and
that's what people think leads to leads
to nihilism once you have fully
explained
why something would be considered
immoral just on evolutionary grounds
you've essentially taken out the the
moral Factor Al together and you're
explaining it in terms of you know
genetic preference yeah there's no more
meaning there's nothing there's no
additional fluff or feeling of anything
but this is you know I've spent a lot of
time over the last few years talking to
evolutionary psychologists evolutionary
biologists people that have looked at
the evolution of culture as well from a
memetic standpoint too and it does seem
to me that culture is is just like
exclusively an Adaptive response to
coordination at Large Scale MH and that
all of the things that are encoded in
that are effective ways for your tribe
to not blow itself up would you say the
same thing about morality in general yes
so then how do you escape this this
nihilist conundrum that that you think
all it is you know the reason why you're
not killing people is just because you
sort of evolved that way doesn't that
kind of take out some of the meaning so
I think if you were permanently self
assessing why you do the things you do
and the inputs that you feel but what
that doesn't account for is the fact
that we are self-deceptive quite right
yeah and the sense of being a human is
one that is imbued with meaning I often
use this term about how um you are not
personally cursed as a a reassurance and
it was something that was reassuring to
me if I was was spending a bit of time
where I was feeling sad or down or
whatever uh it would feel like whatever
emotion I was going through whatever
unpleasant emotion I was going through
was like a personal curse and this makes
sense when you look back at how the gods
were personified as different sorts of
emotions right that you know Cupid had
an arrow that hit you or that you know
you had gods of War you had Gods of
Wrath you had gods of envy you had gods
of narcissism because it the experience
of a thing of a thought of an emotion of
state is not just the confused chemical
signals of your body and now I can just
reverse engineer this even the inter the
interaction of you and whatever's going
on in the social group around you isn't
just that it's imbued with meaning
because you interpret things in this
soup of experience which scales things
up from just what's happening to and it
feels like there's something there feels
like there's some there there right yes
yeah yeah you you can't escape that
illusion if it is an illusion this is
another thing that I spoke to to Ben
about first name first name basis it
seems now Mr um Mr sh I did I did try
that in you know when I was emailing
back and forth about setting up that
event I I was I went to type out sort of
like well oh it would be great to talk
to Mr Shapiro about it just didn't feel
right you know I just couldn't bring
myself to do it um at least not behind
his back not to say that I'm rude behind
his back but it felt even weirder that
he wasn't there to sort of appreciate
the courtesy anyway he said like you
know that I don't believe in Free Will I
don't know if you believe in Free Will
perhaps we can talk about that he's like
look you don't you don't believe in free
will but but you you act as if Free Will
does exist all the time and I remember
thinking what do you mean what what do
it what does it look like to act as
though Free Will doesn't exist the very
argument or one of the arguments against
free will is that you are essentially
driven by your biology your your genes
your your will you know the the Arthur
shophow line that you can do what you
will you just can't will what you will
in fact you have to do what you will
that's that's what that's what drives
Behavior if that's the case then then
why do you have this Vision in your head
that if you lack a belief in Free Will
you're like not going to get out of bed
in the morning the very argument is that
you will get out of bed in the morning
because you desire to go and get some
breakfast that's like the whole point
and so any argument of that form where
people say well you don't live like
that's the case I always like to to to
think what would it look like to you
then you know if I could ask Jordan
Peterson when he says well you don't
live like an atheist what would that
look like to you and I don't know if he
might say something like well you'd
probably be this this morally depraved
you know self-interested blah blah blah
like maybe but is that really what you
think I mean I don't know but yeah I
think it it it forgets the fact that you
are a product of your time regardless of
your beliefs from that time right I
understand the judeo-christian values
that everything is based on you know
it's like a common talking point from
those guys but okay how am I supposed to
extricate me from that completely shake
the etcher sketch of my value set and
then take it from the beginning and
let's not forget like a lot of those
values have grown out of what would have
been an Adaptive response in any case
yeah so the illusion is there the
illusion is unshakable and so it sort of
is a bit senseless to me to us
particularly on the Free Will thing like
why don't you act like free world
doesn't exist what what do you mean I I
I literally it's unintelligible to me
did you listen to my spolski episode yet
no I don't think so so his new book
determined science life without Free
Will um every time that I talk about
free will people get upset why is that
that's the question for you I think the
reason inert joke about how it's not
their fault ha it's like my least
favorite genre of joke that's that's
done no free of my own in philosophy
it's every single time no free of my
yeah um I don't know I don't know and
it's something that the conversation
about Free Will is such a turnoff for
people that I actively push it further
into episodes I actively don't title
episodes that have got that in it I can
uh surreptitiously coax people into
thinking about it but the response is is
very it's a lot amount of high amount of
dissatisfaction people don't like to
think about that now it may be
because it's
dry I'm open to that that's true um it
may be because it threatens their sense
of agency and sovereignty which is
something I've kind of built this
channel off the back of like you can
enact change within your own life
internalize your locus of control stop
being such a [__] Etc uh and so maybe
I'm a
a like the a victim of My Own Foundation
in that regard that I've selected for a
particular group of people but it's
happened a few times few different
conversations about it tangential um one
guy was a compatib like quasi
compatibilist uh shaking your head why
are you shaking your head
I that that it's just the most ludicrous
compromise to me comp compatibilism can
I can I am I right in saying that
compatibilism just kicks the can down
the road and plays lexical overload with
things I think more or less right A lot
of the time you're just also dealing
with essentially a redefinition of free
will it's what I don't mean that I mean
this thing yeah yeah Sam Harris has
called it the uh the the Atlantis
fallacy he he had an extended argument
with Daniel dennet a compati list about
Free Will and Daniel dennet would would
talk about all about how this exists and
this exists and this and and Sam was
like yeah that that's true but you're
just not talking about what people care
about in Free Will what you're doing is
we're trying to ask if Atlantis exists
and you're pointing to Venice and you're
saying look here's a city it's you know
got a lot of water and and it it's it's
kind of old and and these are all true
but but it's it's just not Atlantis yeah
and what most people are talking about
when they try to bring free will back
into the discussion is just not free
will it's as straightforward as it gets
in my view I mean there are versions of
Freedom that that can be sensibly uh
believed in it kind of depends on what
your conception of Freedom means but if
you mean something like authorship over
your actions if you mean that we could
have rewound the clock and I could have
done something differently that I could
have worn a different shirt
I don't think that the answer is is is
yes logically yes you know the possible
world's discussion earlier there's a
possible world where I'm in a different
shirt but I guess like physically
possibly metaphysically I couldn't have
made a different Choice well regardless
possible regardless of what you believe
or don't believe about free will uh the
response people's response to it is
fascinating to me absolutely fascinating
and maybe yeah maybe it is that degree
of control almost like the denial of
death like I wonder have they done
experiments on when people are reminded
that they do or do not have free will
that their behavior adjusts not that I
know of but I would love to see that
because if it is I maybe it is true but
I think if it is true I I can understand
why it might be quite like fatalistic I
mean it literally is quite fatalistic
really to to say that there's no freedom
and I can understand why that might make
someone sad and that sadness might
motivate their behaviors slightly
differently but I think that
intrinsically if there way to control
for people who are sort of happy or sad
about it because you can believe in
there's no Free Will and and be like
thank goodness it's all out of my hands
if you can control for that and show
that people do they are like less
productive or or they you know don't get
out of bed as much then then I think
that would be meaningful and and it
might be a sort of second order reason
not to have this conversation I I don't
know if there's been such a such a
investigation as that has a death which
by the way I think the a good example of
the death denial thing is to think about
your your magnumopus if you if you were
sort of working
on the great life work or something and
you're about to die and and you're just
about to sort of to to finish it off
suppose you found out that after you
publish this and you die a week later
you found out that a meteor was going to
come and destroy the Earth everybody
dies does that make you more or less
enthusiastic about finishing your
project
now for most people I think it's it's
going to make them less enthusiastic it
would certainly make me less
enthusiastic but why what's the
difference to you it doesn't make a
difference you're going to be dead
beforehand anyway nothing's going to
change seems to suggest that maybe you
know the the desire to get this done
before you die in the first place isn't
just as people like to claim for the for
the love of the art and it's all in the
process no it's because here's a work
that's going to outlive you here's
something that's going to help you to
escape your own death and when faced
with the inevitability of the
destruction of even that the motivation
goes down down I wouldn't be surprised
if simply reminding somebody who's
writing a play or something that one day
heat death everything evaporates
including your new book if that would
make them less motivated to finish the
book which to me implies that that the
the reverse collery is that the reason
you are making the book isn't in some
way indebted to the fact that you think
it will outlive you and therefore is an
exercise in the denial of death didn't
Ernest Becka die at an unfortunate time
I don't know much about his personal
life I think he did but there there are
some yeah there there are interesting
coincidences like that dotted across a
lot of the thing about coincidences is
that is that so many things happen all
the time that the only extraordinary
thing would be if there weren't some
extraordinary things like that like
alberu was killed in a in a car crash
and he was killed in the a car crash
with a with a train ticket in his pocket
so it seemed like he decided at the last
minute to go in the car instead and he
had previously said that the most absurd
way to die would be in a in an
automobile accident and that's how he
dies Sigman Freud was terrified of I I
think it was the number
63 it was like 63 or or maybe it was
maybe it was like 48 I can't remember it
one one of the a number around around
that he was just terrified of it had had
a real sort of forb boing about it for
some reason and he he got a phone number
that ended in that number and it freaked
him out he got a hotel room that had
that number and and and he just became
convinced that he was going to die at
that age guess when he died 48 no when
he was like 80 sometimes it it goes
wrong you're a dick you are a dick rest
of that was true though all right what's
your sexy Paradox that you wanted to
show me oh yes get Paradox out the lad
think think about this right um now I I
I can't remember what the source is and
I want to attribute the person who does
it um maybe I can find it get let me
find it because I I want to make sure
that they get the they get the credit
for it I was told about it by a friend
and um
you have to give me a minute because I
want to I don't want to you know pass
this off as my own we you do with
everything
else I think it's called the yeah the
anthropic so so it's a website called
rising Rising entropy. comom um is is is
seemingly the origin of this Paradox but
I was told about it by a friend and it's
it's I guess okay so
imagine that and what this does is it is
it shows us that different ways of
thinking
give us wildly different answers to the
same problem different ways of like
looking at a problem so imagine that
there's a
maniac who and and it's called the
anthropic dice killer if you want to
look it up there's a maniac who is
kidnapping people and murdering them and
what he does is he kidnaps one
person and he blindfolds them and he
rolls a
dice and if that dice is a six then
it'll kill you if not he'll let you go
free and what he'll do if he lets you go
free is he'll go and pick up two people
kidnap them blindfold them roll the dice
if it's a six kills you if it's anything
else go free then it's four people then
it's eight people and it it doubles so
it's an exponential until he hits a six
until he hits a six now you wake up
knowing all this information you wake up
blindfolded and you know you know these
facts and you know that the dice is
about to be rolled but you're
blindfolded you don't know how many
people are there with you you're given a
button that you can press that will make
the chances that you're killed half one
and
two so if you want to you can press this
button and 50% of the time it will just
kill you immediately and 50% of the time
you'll get to go free or you can let him
roll the dice okay what do you do do you
press the button or not so at least on
the surface this is to do with the
probability of one in six versus one in
two yeah but there is this escalation
thing that's happening in the background
so I would presume that you would say
don't hit the
button because that has increased the
chance of you being killed from one in
six to one in two right which great and
this and this seems true and and it it
is true that yeah I mean like you've got
a one and six chance of dying and if you
press the button youve got a one and two
so you're better off rolling the dies
but if you think about
it as a as a sort of uh as one big block
then then something very strange happens
because if you consider all of the
people involved if all you know is that
you've sort of woken up and you're
somewhere in this
process
then interestingly like say it gets to
number two it gets to round two then
there have been three people involved
three victims involved first one and
second two and two of them end up dying
and one of them goes free mhm so if you
find yourself in this situation as a
victim
you've got a more than half probability
that you're in the second group that
ends up
dying I suppose that actually it ends in
the third
group right now there are how many
people involved you got one then two
then four then four yeah so we've now
got seven people
involved right and four people end up
dying and so if if you sort of wake up
in this scenario you've got a four in
seven chance that you're going to die
that you're going to be one of the
people who dies which is more than half
and this continues such that if you
consider the fact that that it doesn't
matter where it
ends you're always going to have a
slightly higher than half chance that
you're in the group that ends up getting
killed
but is it is it more than half given
that each round of the dice roll is only
one in
six
yeah because it's about like if in in
fact it gets to number three right like
you know you know that you're going to
be in the
the there's a more than half chance that
you're going to be in the group that
dies if it if it in fact gets to number
two then there's a more than half chance
that that that you're going to die if it
in fact gets number four so I'm going to
hit the button is that right well maybe
I I mean it seems ludicrous to hit the
button but but thinking about it this
way it seems like that's what you should
actually do it's simultaneously the case
that you have got a one and six chance
of dying because you're doing it on the
role of a
dice but at the same time if you think
about the fact that that one of these
groups is going to end up dying and it
doesn't matter where it ends the chances
of you being in that group are always
going to be slightly higher than half
right from a a population level the
anthropic dice Kor because it's the
anthropic principle is he thinking about
yeah what's
that I once read a Sci-Fi book uh that
was there was a threat of the end of the
world and they were looking to get
Humanity off the planet and there is a
theory that uses almost this exact same
idea which says
that if you take the entirety of human
history and you were to pick a time at
which you were to live and you have this
rapid increase toward Humanity it works
out that it's it's more likely that you
are within some percent of the end of
humanity right yeah because of itial
growth precisely are you familiar with
this idea I don't think so but itting
the same kind works the exact same yeah
as long as that graph is going up at the
at the requisite speed then then yeah
right and this is the exact same thing I
mean the the the version on the website
actually involves Snake Eyes so so it's
two dice and instead of it being one
then two then four it's one then 10 then
100 then a thousand they get K it ramps
up more quick and now and now you're
rolling snake ey so so it's a one and 36
chance and it turns out that if you add
up the probability of of of like you
know n number of cases it it's something
like a 90% chance versus the half that
you get to press which just seems
ludicrous and it seems two things are
true at once depending on just how you
look at the problem so sometimes
problems like this are just to do with
the way you word them I mean there are
tons of like these sort of interesting
math paradoxes which aren't paradoxes at
all you must be familiar with the man
who walks into the hotel pays 303 goes
up to his room and the bell booy says or
or or the guy behind the bar says the
manager
says oh no he should have only paid 25
we've got a deal on so he calls the bell
boy and says can you go and give him5
back to the man in the room and the b
boy thinks to himself on the way up like
this guy doesn't know any better he
doesn't know how much he owed I'm going
to I'm going to pocket three pound for
myself I'm only going to give him two
pound so he goes back to the room he
says excuse me sir sorry you paid you
know you paid 30 pounds you paid too
much Here's 2 p change so how much has
the man now
paid 25 no 28 28 and how much has the
bell boy got in his pocket
two he gave the he gave the guy two
pounds
back right where's that money come from
yeah he's got three so the B boy so the
man's now only paid 28 he's paid £3 he
gets two pound back from the bell boy so
he's got he's paid 28s the B boy's got
three pounds in his pocket which makes
31 so where's the extra pound come from
actually no he hasn't the guy paid 25
plus now he's got two back that's right
so it it's it's the way you word it so
like stps people and you can do it the
other way around as well you can say
that the guy goes up and he
gives the B boy gives three3 back to the
guy so he's only paid 27 but the B boy's
got he's got it's only and it's only 29
and and this you know it sort of goes
viral on social media because people are
like how the hell does it work it's the
uh blue and black or green and gold
dress it's like I mean for those that
yeah I guess there is it's like those
and that there is a real answer to what
the what the actual what's actually
going on there I based on how how you
word it it's how people you know Short
change when when they when they scam
people at a at a at a bar or something I
mean the easiest way to to visualize
that particular problem is to imagine
that the man was only supposed to pay2
you know so the B boy goes up and gives
him 28 he's supposed to give him £28 and
decides to pocket two P for himself you
say oh so he gives him you know gives
him 26 back so how much has the man paid
like4 and how much the wild boy got
like26 which is ludicrous but you'd be
how easily people can be completely nly
stumped by it and it's all in the it's
all in the wording so a problem like the
anthropic dice killer I wonder how
much is just sort of to do with the the
way that you describe it you know have
there been any uh paradoxes that sent
you into a fug state for a little while
was there anything that captured a
particularly long amount of time that
you sort of couldn't stop considering
H um
well most of the famous ones since since
I first started learning about paradoxes
like the famous Monty Hall problem that
that that obsessed me for for well I
wouldn't say obsessed me but I was I was
sort of Blown Away by it there's also
you know the multile problem that you'll
definitely have heard of this before
this
um it's the game show and the three
doors right yeah you know what I'm right
um there are interesting paradoxes that
aren't actually paradoxes there's
there's a book by Jim Al KH called
paradox which is a description of SoCal
paradoxes so like I think I think's
Paradox
is when people used to think that the
Universe was
infinite infinitely large I mean there
was this problem that if if empty space
is filled up fairly randomly with stars
I mean we know there's a lot of stars in
the sky and and galaxies and objects
that emit light then there should
essentially be no darkness in the sky
the sky should look kind of like an
overcast day because like the the the
gaps in the sky you
know going to be fild up and any amount
any small Gap you might think the stars
are really far away they'll also be like
closer together therefore emitting more
light visually and they'll be bigger and
and and so if the universe is infinite
you should just see a sort of overcast
day and it it was a paradox it was like
how does this how does this happen and
it basically became an interesting proof
that the universe has a beginning that
the universe is not in fact infinite
just the fact that it gets dark at night
because if it were actually infinite
there should be a
a sort of overcast view ol's Paradox and
like I say it's sort of a paradox but
not really a paradox familiar with the
bues void do you know this I think so
this is like my favorite part of the
universe I'd say like I'm mapping it
like my favorite barbecue restaurants in
Austin and it's a huge what's what's
referred to as a super void which is a a
period of the universe an area of the
universe which has way fewer galaxies in
than you would anticipate and given
what's the principle of like homogenity
across the universe that it should be it
should be relatively similar right like
thermodynamics yes that it should
entropy and and you just now you're just
saying space words at me well you know
like when you spray spray in aerosol can
and it will eventually equally so the
point is that
there shouldn't
be huge fluctuations in the way that we
see the universe everything should be
spread relatively evenly now I found out
that um supposedly at the point of the
Big Bang there were 1 million particles
of antimatter and 1 million and one
particles of matter and it is that one
to 1
million and one ratio that is exactly
where everything that we see comes from
and this minor imbalance is actually
what's permitted everything to exist but
this particular bues B one with an um
out tees bua super void uh it's just
super [__] interesting it's this Gap
where there's way fewer galaxies than
there should be why should this exist
given that we've got this sort of
principle of homogeneity Across the
Universe and that's one of my favorite
things to like learn about yeah it's
it's a but is it is it that we know
about this void because of the the
disbalance or is it that we hypothesize
the disbalance because of the the the
knowledge of the Void we know based on
mapping of I think uh I'm not sure if
it's telescopic or if it's microwave
background stuff but we know that it's
there right and the question is what the
[__] is this thing doing that yeah well
that's a bit like sort of dark energy
when we discover that galaxies are
spinning a little bit too quickly on the
outside there seems to be something like
pushing them along what do you make of
the um fine chune Universe idea uh a lot
of people describe it as as the most
powerful argument for God's existence
Christopher Hitchens in the back of a
car once said that that was really what
what gave him pause I don't find that it
moves me very much I mean it does seem
quite extraordinary that had any of the
constants of the universe the force of
gravity for example if it was stronger
or weaker by the most unimaginably small
amount then it would either be strong
enough that the Universe would collapse
in on itself or it would be uh so weak
that you atoms couldn't even form or or
at least objects couldn't form and
everything just gets blown apart at the
Big Bang
um three explanations for this it's it's
chance it's necessity or its design and
Chan is seems like a ludicrous
suggestion I mean there are lots of
different constants and it may be the
case that we discover this sort of
theory of everything that reduces it
down to one still a huge mystery as to
why it has the sort of the constant that
it does but
would mean that we're not talking about
lots of different constants in harmony
uh somehow happens to be unified one way
the idea of it sort of necessarily being
that way doesn't seem that out of the
question for me
like people people put it in the
language of saying that had the
constants been different by this amount
the universe couldn't exist and what
people often hear is the
chances of the constant being as it was
was the same number but I don't think
that's the same thing it might just not
possible that it could have had a
different value what's that is it the
Observer selection effect of this this
doesn't work for the fine-tuning
argument I I think so the so-called like
anthropic principle the universe seems
designed for human life it seems OD like
people might point to for
example the Earth's perfect distance
from the Sun in the so-called goldilock
Zone had it been a little bit further
out or a little bit closer humans
couldn't exist and the easy answer to
that is to say well yeah but if you
didn't exist then you wouldn't be there
to observe that it didn't exist right
and so you say given the size of the
universe life might develop somewhere
possibly multiple places and the places
where it's going to be
observed coming about is where it comes
about so no surprise that works there
but the the fine tuning concepts of the
universe we're not talking about
like we're not talking about like a
potential billions of earths that could
all give R to human beings we're talking
about if one of these constants was
different by a tin by the tiniest amount
nothing exists and and sure it is still
true that didn't not happen we wouldn't
be here to observe it yeah my my my
friend Josh Peri has given me an example
in the past of like I don't know you can
imagine like a series of highly
trained knife throwers just just just
just lob like 100,000 knives at you in
an attempt to kill you and they all Miss
perfectly cutting out the silhouette of
your body behind you absolutely
perfectly just like uncanny and someone
says well they must have done that on
purpose it's like a trick right and you
say no no I I think it's just just
happened by chance you say well that's
ludicrous oh well if it didn't then I
wouldn't be here to to observe that it
did would I it it still just wouldn't
wouldn't do it for you even though that
is true you know had you been killed you
wouldn't be there to observe it it just
seems such an unlikely coincidence that
that just doesn't work for the when
we're talking about the actual
fundamental uh stuff of of the universe
which is why people are so troubled by
it but I do think generally speaking
with all of these kinds of things
fine-tuning Consciousness is another
example that's broadly in the scientific
real realm that people think that this
just can't be explained without
reference to a God maybe they're right I
don't know but if you intuitively were
to step into a time machine and look at
some people having this
conversation and you said
like like imagine them looking back and
and saying gosh can you believe it they
hadn't worked out fine tuning yet they
hadn't figured out the constants are
they hadn't figured out the science of
con Consciousness yet I can I can
conceive of that just just intuitively I
can see someone doing that but when I
think about my Arguments for atheism the
problem of evil Divine hiddenness this
kind of stuff I can't imagine somebody
looking through a time machine similarly
at a conversation that I have and going
gosh can you believe it they hadn't
worked out the problem of evil yet they
hadn't worked out Divine hiddenness yet
I think these are perennial problems so
where you have these scientific
Arguments for the existence of God I
guess I just have more of a trust that
they will one day be explained in a way
that won't require recourse to a Divine
author in in a way that my criticisms of
religion will probably not be similarly
resolved we had a great conversation in
Austin as you explained to me about the
potential historical accuracy or
inaccuracy of Jesus's
resurrection can you go through that a
little bit yeah I mean this sometimes is
used as an argument for the existence of
God but I think more successfully is
used once you've already establish the
existence of God to to try to establish
the truth of Christianity and that is a
bunch of historical facts
surrounding Jesus's uh alleged
resurrection that you sort of have to
ask what the best explanation is for now
you can't historically prove a
resurrection but you can historically
prove events and then ask what the
best best explanation of those facts is
so people will often point to the fact
that there was a man called Jesus
walking around morally teaching people
who was crucified by the Romans and that
a few days after his death was seen or
people made claims that they hadd seen
him uh after he died and the question is
how do you explain these facts the
gospel reliability is an interesting
question in general and people will
often on the surface level say look the
Bible contradicts itself it's full of
contradictions and there are some
seeming contradictions in in the gospel
stories but of of course what a lot of
people neglect to consider is that when
we're talking about a text as a
historical document contradictions
shouldn't make us think that it's uh
like less accurate but more
accurate if historical sources
contradict each other that's evidence of
their accuracy rather than evidence of
the opposite
because if this is a mythical story that
somebody's making
up you would expect the details to
concur that is if you're questioning two
suspects in some kind of murder trial or
something and their stories match up
perfectly like to the tea the timings
everything it arouses suspicion seems
like somebody's inventing something
someone's coming up with a story here
and trying to trying to perfect it now
people have this idea that a bunch of
people got together and tried to fool
the world into this sort of mythical
story of of you know this man rising
from the dead do you think they would
have made the mistake of just including
these blatant
contradictions I don't know in other
words I think if somebody was making it
up they probably would have taken more
care is there a term for this I'm sure
there is right I'm not a historian I
couldn't tell you what it is um
but we we we do see contradictions on
the minor
points we don't really see much
disagreement about the major points I
mean there is still enough disagreement
that I think to arouse suspicion I mean
I'm saying this as if I'm some kind of
Christian or or theist I sort of put on
that hat when when I'm asked to have a
conversation of this kind I mean it does
seem to me suspicious for example that
the gospel of Mark which is the earliest
gospel contains no post-resurrection
appearances and then the gospel of
Matthew does include post-resurrection
appearances the Gospel of Luke includes
even more it's only in the Gospel of
John that we get for instance dting
Thomas which is the the latest gospel um
canonical gospel I should say that's
where that arises and in fact the story
of doubting Thomas
famously he doesn't believe that it's
the Risen Christ and Jesus says come and
touch my wounds and he touches his
wounds and he and he and he says my Lord
and my god um and Jesus
says you believed because you've seen
blessed are those who believe without
seeing so in my view what we have is
this so-called mythological development
of no post-resurrection appearances and
as the time goes on as we get further
away from the source stories get more
Fantastical ending in a moral a moral
lesson to believe without evidence yes
yeah this to me does seem a little bit
suspicious so it's it is a fascinating
mystery like uh you know something very
strange happened on Easter morning
because how do we explain the fact that
this man gets crucified by the Romans
and then people claim to see him after
he died and we're willing to be put to
death for that belief now okay maybe he
didn't die unlikely as they say the
Romans knew how to kill people and
supposedly you know they check and they
go to they go to to to break the legs of
the other prisoners as they're taking
them down from from from their their
their crosses uh they were taking them
down sort of temporarily and they hadn't
died yet but when they go to break
Jesus's legs they realize he's already
dead which is why his legs don't get
broken and they and they stab him in the
side with a stick to make sure that he's
dead I mean you know like this was a
very effective method of killing people
and they knew how to do it so it's
unlikely that he just somehow survived
this um is that the guy that stabbed him
with the spear and supposedly this Blood
on the spear was this he get someone STS
him with the spear like after after the
right after he's on the cross and it's
essentially to check his dead um okay so
likelihood is that he was actually
crucified and then a few days later
people are claiming to see him maybe
they're lying but then you don't tend to
go to death for something you know to be
a
lie you're willing to be put to death
for things that you think are true that
are false but very rarely are people
willing to die for beliefs that they
don't actually believe themselves that
doesn't really happen so they probably
weren't lying as maybe they were maybe
they were mistaken fooled yeah now I I
I've known you since about
2019 which is probably it would have
been slightly longer than Jesus was with
his disciples
but spending every single day with this
person living with this person eating
with this
person and then you've only seen him a
few days ago and somehow imagine
somebody managed to convince you that
they were
me even if I had a twin brother they
probably wouldn't be able to convince
you that it was me or maybe they were
hallucinating in
groups the one of the earliest
uh gospel New Testament sources is the
is the the letters of Paul the earliest
and in one of those letters Paul refers
to Jesus having appeared to 500 people
all at once and in some of the gospels
you get at least some group appearances
at least more than one person and
sometimes you know groups of disciple
the the TW all seeing Jesus all at once
you don't get group hallucinations like
that and so it doesn't seem like they
were they were they were mistaken either
and so if they're not mistaken they're
not making it up what explains the fact
that these people claim to see him after
he had died and the the
the Christian apologists will say that
the only real plausible explanation is
that he really did rise from the dead
now it's a it's a interesting argument
and it's quite powerful
however my my response has always been
that this sort of process of elimination
is very clever and that's how it it's
usually run but it can go the other way
I mean imagine I were trying to prove
that there was such thing as a group
hallucination I know it's extraordinary
but there was a group hallucination and
I tried to prove it by saying well what
are the other explanations or maybe they
lied well they wouldn't do that because
they wouldn't go to death or maybe a man
rose from the dead but come on that
doesn't happen that that breaks all the
laws of physics so the only remaining
option is this kind of depends where you
start but it is weird something very
strange seems to have happened on that
morning I can see why philosophers go
mad because you were able to
simultaneously convince yourself of
something and then convince yourself of
the opposite and unconvince yourself of
everything that you've believed yeah but
that's
I think one of those famous quotes of
Socrates is that you know the the sign
of wisdom in a man or something is is
the ability to entertain a belief
without holding it or without becoming
convinced by it or something like that
and I I think it's um something anybody
can do if they want to it's and it's why
philosophers are so people think that
philosophers are better at doing this I
don't think that's true I think they're
just talking about stuff that's far less
far less political far less real and so
so they're less likely to get they're
less likely to to be offended at the
prospect of considering the falsehood of
their of their beliefs maybe until you
get into religion I suppose you
definitely seem to be able to have an
ability to drop into and out of
arguments on both sides of the same
fence and play with ideas in a way that
I think is is rare and presumably a bit
of a disposition but also largely
trained because you can sit and convince
chat
GPT that God exists
or try and turn me into a theist and
then stand on stage and do the exact
opposite uh and just I I think that
there's probably quite a lot to learn
from how people who have spent a good
bit of time playing with ideas in
philosophy dispassionately have that
separation between themselves and the
idea and the belief and what it means to
them and the emotion and kind of that
whole like ambient mess yeah it's
playing is is a good word because it's
fun you know it's enjoyable that's why
it's it's fun to talk about you know
theory of knowledge because who like
really cares it doesn't you know it
doesn't grow corn as they say or make
corn how you however you're supposed to
say it and uh and and that's fine
because if it did then it would suddenly
all get a bit serious and it kind of
really matters whether you get it right
or wrong whereas here we're just sort of
sort of having fun but you can I don't
know I I can kind of see why Heretics
would get burnt at the stake when
religion had Social Power because you
know you you become convinced that this
is the source of meaning this is the
source of truth without it we are
nothing now being threatened and then it
turns out that maybe there are actually
some holes to poke here what are you
going to do I mean you can't let them do
that because this is literally you know
societally calamitous and so you know
they they end up getting burn at the
stake that's what also annoys me I mean
you mentioned earlier this this recent
resech urgence in the idea that oh we're
all sort of balancing on judeo-christian
values may be kind of true in a sense
but it does kind of get on my nerves
that after I said this to Ben yesterday
that the history
of religious persecution against the
very developments that those religious
groups now like to claim as their own I
think the religion has shown to be wrong
on a number of things I listed them
yesterday the position of women in
society the state of homosexuals at
least practicing homosexuals the
position of the Earth in relation to the
sun the age of both of those celestial
bodies wrong about the common
evolutionary ancestry of all animals
including the human
animal wrong about the ownership of
other human beings as private property
as is explicitly condoned not only in
the Old Testament but also in the new
and now not only does religion sort of I
religion fails to come to us with with
an apology and Contrition and say maybe
we were wrong it says no no no those
things are ours all along it says yes we
may have shown the instruments of
torture to Galileo because he suggested
that the Earth might orbit the sun
rather than the other way around but hey
didn't you know that the Scientific
Revolution is essentially
judeo-christian in origin yes the Old
Testament gives you
explicit uh instructions about exactly
how to either buy or steal other human
beings and keep them sometimes as your
sexual property but don't you know that
the Abolitionist Movement is essentially
judeo-christian in
origin yes I know that St Paul says that
man is the glory of God but woman is the
glory of man and that I suffer not a
woman to teach not to Asser authority
over a man rather she should remain
silent for Adam was formed first then
Eve but don't you know that social
justice movements are essentially
judeo-christian in origin yes you know
we we know about the stoning of
homosexuals and the the fact that if
even St Paul says that they're not
getting into heaven but don't you know
that the LGBT movement is essentially
sort of riding on judeo-christian
principles it seems to me relatively
offensive to the people who have managed
to secure these developments against the
very religious Traditions that now like
to claim them as their
own yeah both cause and Def it's like
being punched in the face by somebody
who then comes over and gives you a
bandage for it yes I mean people like to
refer to and this is I'm sort of
rehashing some of the stuff that I said
yesterday
here
it's sort of
a people like to point out that the
the people who really got the Scientific
Revolution going were often Believers in
God you know Galileo believed in God
Newton believed in God in fact Newton
spent but people would fascinated to
discover his Diaries to find that he
spent more time writing about theology
than than science mad man for the last
30 years doing Alchemy right right but
here's the thing right like if and
and as I said yesterday I I don't claim
that this is the case but if it were
true that science had like undermined
religion and Christianity if it were the
case that that actually these things
aren't compatible with each other then
when somebody says well that can't be
the case because don't you know that the
people who sort of founded the
Scientific Revolution were religious
well what else would they have been if
they hadn't yet invented the mechanism
by which their beliefs would come to be
undermined it's like saying that it's
amazing that the person who invented the
Motorcar didn't own a motor car
beforehand you see what I'm saying it
sort of I don't know it seems very
strange to and and it's very recently
that the popularity of this has
increased as you say I mean you go back
to the to the mid- naughties at the
height of new atheism and it was very
popular to talk about how religion's
sort of always getting in the way of
Science and maybe that was a bit crude
but I think we're seeing an equally
crude
annexation
of all of the beneficial social
developments of the past 100 years as
somehow necessarily standing upon the
judeo-christian tradition it couldn't
have happened without them is this a uh
scrabbling for something to hold on to
given that the collapse of grand
narratives has had some poor
externalities over the last couple of
years is it co is it just Mass cope I
think so I think that nihilism as it
were carries with it the feeling of
being naked you you sort of thrown off
what were essentially optional clothes
to reveal what was there all along but
when you
actually face it to Nature it's
embarrassing it's scary and you will do
anything you can if you find yourself
naked in public to find any clothes to
put on not just your old ones doesn't
matter what clothes any clothes are
better than no clothes and this is what
people are beginning to realize and so
they're scrambling for their old clothes
again and trying to legitimate and yes
and and and trying
to trying to put them on um and that's
why it's easy as well for people to go
around poking holes in other people's
clothes it's very easy to do but that's
what the success of a movement like new
atheism consists in in the fact that all
they had to do was just tell other
people why they're wrong you only need
to poke coals in other people's clothes
but if you need to like sew your own
shirt yeah that gets a little more
difficult see as swi said that the the
purpose of philosophy is not the cutting
down of forests but the irrigation of
deserts that's very interesting yeah I
I've thought about this for a good while
um
the seductiveness of being a Critic as
opposed to being somebody that makes
suggestions uh and the lack of
preparedness of anybody to put forward
any proposals for anything you it's easy
for both sides accuse each other of
being reactionary right the reactionary
right the reactionary left uh and
ultimately for instance perfect perfect
example of this is in the world of
dating and sort of mate selection in The
Mating Market uh everybody can provide
criticisms about what's going wrong and
almost nobody provides any action able
steps to improve it Beyond something
that is eliminative rather than additive
right like well if we could just stop
doing this then this would be fixed it's
like I don't think that that's quite the
way that it works and there's another
very unique protection mechanism that's
given which is it's very hard to
criticize someone's criticism or at
least being a a Critic leaves you open
to criticism way less than being a
proposer oh yeah right if I if I put
something forward if I posit a potential
solution for you to be able to come back
and say well this is [__] and this is
[__] and this is [__] makes complete
it's very easy to do whereas for you to
say for me to critic you what you did
and then for you to come back and go
well actually this and this and this
about it's like n it kind of gets all a
little bit abstract and it's a few
degrees removed from anything that feels
real yeah Simon C can't write a
song you know like if the world was full
of Simon cows then we'd end up with no
music somebody's got to do the building
here you can't just be a Critic and this
is what I think
has been the reason for the success of
the sort of anti-n atheist stuff that
we've been seeing recently I mean you'll
have seen this even the new atheist
themselves sort of treat it like it's a
it's a dead animal and in many ways it
is and I think it's got to do with the
fact that yeah they they they've done a
very good job of of cutting down the
central pillar
of what has traditionally been the
reason the people getting out of bed in
the morning and then when people are
there saying well what do we put in its
place they're like see you you know I'm
out and they go off and do different
things and and what are people to do and
that's why was it the job of the new
atheists to provide something to well
maybe not some some people are just good
at diagnosing problems KL marks is a
good
example like K marks is diagnosis of of
of the way the world works are
fascinating to read and Incredibly
useful even if you disagree with them
but obviously attempt to sort of build
uh societies on those ideas alone have
failed seems like you need something a
little bit more um I just don't think
it's true the religion stuff I mean and
so that's why I think we're seeing this
because people are beginning to realize
that it probably isn't true they can't
get like quite get behind the truth
claims but they recognize that there's
some utility in having other people
believe that it is
true and I don't know where that leaves
us because in this discussion about
whether religion is good or bad for
society I said yesterday look I will
accept your premise
wholesale that religion is good maybe
even necessary for society what do you
want me to do if I just don't think it's
true might just lie to my children raise
than believing something that I I don't
believe is the case because I think it
will somehow be beneficial to society I
don't think it works like that I don't
think people can actually fool
themselves sure you can act as if God
exists and that's what someone like
Peterson says that people do already but
ultimately if you just say well I think
that you know it's I should just act
like a Christian because it's good for
me then when push comes to shove and you
really have to make a moral sacrifice if
you're not actually a Christian you're
probably not going to do the actually
Christian thing well I wonder whether
this is afforded to people because of
the convenience and comfort of Modern
Life the fact that having to really
really something on the line it's mostly
Ling as you know belief systems and I'll
pick up that piece of trash and I will
you know give money to this person on
the street yeah people have sort of
forgotten I mean it's like Bourgeois
religious belief it's so so irregularly
that we have to make genuine moral
sacrifices of the kind that used to be
common place throughout the history of
humanity that we've sort of Forgotten
our ability to do so and I think that if
you push people now they they recognize
that they probably wouldn't make those
sacrifices did you see the Mr Beast poll
where he asked would you rather have
like a million dollars or like a random
person on Earth dies or something like
that if you press this button no and
like I think it might have been a
majority of people a slim majority said
they you know press that button yeah
kill kill someone random I'll take a
million bucks and and I actually kind of
believe them I think they actually would
and people want to say that that's
because we've lost you know our belief
in
God I don't know maybe I I think a
better explanation is just that like you
say we've become too comfortable and so
when somebody says in other words like
oh well you know this must be due to due
to to decline in religion and the fact
that we've forgotten our judeo Christian
Heritage I mean you'll probably hear
that a lot from people that you might
talk to on this podcast they'll say
something like that just think to
yourself like is that really the best
explanation is that the only explanation
could it be something to do with the
growth of Technology could it do could
it be to do with something of something
to do with the growth of comfort yeah
and is it more likely to do with that
and maybe it's not the lack of religion
that's causing the other stuff but but
this other source that's causing both of
those things yeah I've been thinking a
lot recently about uh stuff that is
literally true but figuratively false
and figuratively true but literally
false and uh it kind of seems a little
bit like the beliefs that you're talking
about here it may be comforting
increasing in happiness adaptive to kind
of act as if these things exist uh the
belief in free will actually uh
believing in Free Will or sorry yeah
determinism generally is something that
may be literally true but figuratively
false yes and that's kind of where I've
come to as an opinion with this that
largely it's through designed ignorance
that I just don't think about it that
much precisely the reason it evolves
that's why it exists it's an illusion
because it it it does something for us
and and that's fine I have I have I've
never had a problem saying that but when
the sort of opes under which I'm having
a conversation with benjiro is that he
made a video called The Atheist delusion
and in that video he says like look you
can't have free will without God I say
yeah I agree you can't have free will
without God you just also can't have it
with God and he essentially says like
well you know there's sort of a I don't
know how free will works but it's sort
of a mystery that I'm I'm willing to
accept wholesale and I'm like well this
is fine but who's the delery one here
you know what I mean like I I've got no
problem with you saying like well I I
see that this or benter by the way but I
have no problem with somebody saying
well yeah I mean maybe Free Will doesn't
exist but it's better to act as though
it does it's like okay fine but then
don't don't say that I'm the one acting
under a delusion I mean delusions can be
good they might evolve for a good reason
but but I don't know I I guess I find it
difficult to treat something as true
that isn't it's a bit like the gun is
always loaded that's one of Brett
Weinstein's example examples it's it's
not true that the gun is always loaded
but we're just going to pretend that it
is and that's much better that least to
a good Society if we
but like you can't actually act like
it's true like if you ask me to put
money on like opening the gun and seeing
if there's a bullet in there you can
behave in a way that functions as if it
were but then when push comes to shove
and you really need to make a decision
yeah you're not going to be able to do
it unless you really believe it so this
only works in low stakes situations yeah
so so you know it's it's all too easy to
say oh you know we we'll just we'll just
sort of act as though it's true good
example here using the using the act as
if the gun is loaded thing uh you do not
point it at anybody you do not leave it
around the children you do not do the
rest of it if a uh robber breaks into
your house you don't go downstairs with
said gun acting as if it's loaded
exactly exactly right and so the moment
that it actually really matters like in
the prior case it only matters when it
goes wrong right but when it begins to
matter when it goes right and that it
goes right this principle just doesn't
work and so I'm I'm suspicious of his
efficacy in other words I think we might
need to actually start acting in
accordance with what's true which by the
way is what people have been saying for
a long time oh why don't we all just act
in accordance with what's true and then
suddenly when you begin to realize that
maybe Free Will doesn't exist maybe
morality is just a social adaptation
suddenly this idea of acting in
accordance with what's true as as a as a
point of principle goes out the window
and it's amazing how I've I I sort of
see deontologists virtue ethicists
transform before my very eyes into
utilitarians out out goes the principle
of live in accordance with the truth
outgo the principles of
honesty and and sort of lack of
intentional self-deception because well
we want the greatest good for the
greatest number you know a better more
functional Society comes about if we
just pretend as though this is the case
what happened to The Virtue what
happened to the principle what happened
to the deontological ethics it's just
out the window all of a sudden I think
sometimes people like to have their cake
and eat it too in that respect I like to
act in accordance with what I think is
true and when somebody challenges me and
says well you don't act as as though you
don't have free will I I just don't know
what that means I don't know what that
looks like it probably looks something
like this Alex okon ladies and gentlemen
Alex it's been a while since I've had
you on I think I'm going to be joining
you on your show at some point soon hope
so what can people expect of you over
the next couple of months what's coming
up uh hopefully that conversation with
benir which I'll mention for 16
billionth time uh we will be will be out
I've got a few debates coming up Oxford
Union Durham Union something at
Cambridge on the
monarchy uh so you're being known for
the appear Morgan's propelled you
catapulted you to the Forefront of the
anti-monarchist yeah I'm becoming
something of a royal correspondent for
for for that news new an anti- Royal
correspondant hey my my Twitter bio is
growing growing by the minute on this
podcast where should people go they want
to keep up to date with the stuff you do
uh just type in my name Alex of Conor I
am technically still Cosmic skeptic uh
that's my old handle I tend to go by my
Christian name now but the handles are
still all there so you'll still find me
that way too Alex I appreciate you thank
you mate thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that episode you will
love my fulllength 2hour Long podcast
with Douglas Murray go
on press it